en este vídeo hablaremos sobre los pares
conjugados ha sido base y vamos a
empezar con la idea de un par conjugado
ha sido base usando una reacción como
ejemplo
veamos una reacción entre el ácido
fluorhídrico hf y el agua entonces el
ácido fluorhídrico es un ácido débil que
al ponerlo en agua se disocia
parcialmente es decir que sólo una parte
del hf se disocia 'va en iones floruro y
iones h más pero estos iones h más serán
donados al agua y así el agua se
convierte en h 3 o más hidronew y este
proceso se encuentra en un equilibrio
dinámico porque puede ir hacia una
dirección o hacia otra y eventualmente
la velocidad de las dos será igual y por
lo tanto ocurrirán al mismo tiempo así
que en esta reacción están sucediendo
muchas cosas
vamos a enfocarnos primero en los iones
de hidrógeno que son intercambiados
entonces si sólo analizamos el ácido
fluorhídrico y en la reacción hacia la
derecha podemos ver que nuestro hf se
transforma en efe - y eso lo logra al
donar o perder un protón pondré a un
signo menos que significa que está
perdiendo y está perdiendo un protón
entonces nuestro hf pierde un protón y
así nos queda efe - el guión fluoruro y
ahora podemos analizar el mismo proceso
pero ahora con la reacción inversa
miren si analizamos la reacción inversa
que ocurre al mismo tiempo el ión
fluoruro puede tomar o aceptar un protón
de algún lado
entonces como toma unas yemas vamos a
poner un signo más aquí
y así cuando el fluoruro acepta a un
protón podemos reformar nuestro hf
entonces observen que el hf y el efe -
tienen una relación muy especial porque
podemos formar a uno o al otro al perder
o ganar un protón y también ocurre algo
parecido entre el agua y el idóneo aquí
el agua está aceptando un protón de laxe
efe así que el agua gana un protón y se
convierte en idóneo ahora en la reacción
inversa el hidro no puede perder un
protón y así regresamos al agua entonces
menos h más
ok así que nuevamente tenemos dos
especies el agua y el hidro neo que
están relacionadas entre sí por tener o
no un h más en química a estas especies
que se relacionan de esta forma les
llamamos pares conjugados ácido base y
la definición oficial o más bien mi
definición oficial de un par conjugado
ha sido base es que cuando tenemos dos
especies que están relacionadas entre sí
vamos a ver dos especies que están
relacionadas entre sí relacionadas por
un h más h más en este caso tenemos hf y
efe - que se relacionan por s h más
entonces hf y efe - son un par conjugado
ha sido base y también tenemos agua e
hidrógeno que también están relacionados
por un h más entonces el agua
y el h3 o más también son un par
conjugado ha sido base y tal vez lo
puedan deducir por el nombre siempre que
tengamos un par conjugado ha sido base
uno será un ácido y el otro siempre será
una base la definición de cuál es el
ácido y cuál es la base proviene de la
definición de ácidos y bases de
brondsted lowry miren la definición de
brondsted lowry dice que cualquier cosa
que pueda donar un h más es un ácido
entonces podemos ver que en este caso el
ácido fluorhídrico actúa como un ácido
en el parc conjugado ácido base y eso
significa que el ión fluoruro debe de
estar actuando como una base y eso tiene
sentido porque la teoría de brondsted
laurie sobre una base dice que es algo
que acepta a un h más y eso es
exactamente lo que ocurre observen que
en la reacción inversa toma un h más
para volver a formar el ácido y podemos
hacer lo mismo con el agua y el h3 o más
y el agua gana un protón lo acepta así
que el agua actúa como una base
y luego en la reacción inversa h tres o
más dona un protón por lo que el h tres
o más actúa como un ácido
ahora podemos escribir la relación entre
los pares conjugados ha sido base un
poco más generalizada
mire si representamos cualquier ácido
general como h
este es nuestro ácido ya dijimos que un
nacido es algo que dona un protón
entonces pierde un protón y así se forma
la base conjugada que la podemos
representar como a menos
ahora en la reacción inversa nuestra
base a menos puede ganar un protón y así
reformar el ácido o ácido conjugado
entonces siempre que tengamos dos
especies que básicamente tengan la misma
fórmula en este caso la abreviados como
a menos
excepto que una tiene un h más y la otra
no así es cómo podemos saber que tenemos
un par conjugado ha sido base veamos más
ejemplos de pares conjugados ha sido
base bueno arriba vimos un ejemplo con
hf ácido fluorhídrico y su base
conjugada es efe - entonces aquí hf es
nuestro ácido y cuando pierde el protón
sólo nos queda
efe - y también en la misma reacción
vimos que el agua puede actuar como una
base entonces el agua sería nuestra a
menos y si el agua acepta a un protón
puede formar el ácido conjugado h3 o más
entonces en este ejemplo hf es un ácido
débil pero también podemos hablar de la
base con jugada de un ácido fuerte como
por ejemplo el ácido clorhídrico hcl es
un ácido fuerte eso significa que se
disocia completamente dona todos sus
protones y cuando eso pasa nos queda la
base conjugada cloruro y miren aun
cuando el cloruro no es particularmente
básico es la base con jugada del hcl y
bueno finalmente veamos dos ejemplos en
donde parece que tenemos un par
conjugado ha sido base pero en realidad
no un ejemplo sería qué pasa con la
relación entre h 3 o más y h - bueno si
pensamos en que el ácido es el h 3 o más
si perdemos un protón vimos que la base
conjugada es el agua y si el agua pierde
un protón entonces nos quedaría o h -
así que la diferencia entre estas dos
especies
es de dos protones en lugar de uno por
lo tanto el idóneo y el hidróxido no son
un par conjugado ha sido base porque
difieren por dos protones en lugar de
uno ok
en el último ejemplo que veremos dijimos
que el fluoruro es la base conjugada de
hf pero qué pasa con la relación entre
el fluoruro de sodio y el fluoruro bueno
estos dos tampoco son un par conjugado
ha sido base porque si el ión fluoruro
acepta a un protón no obtenemos fluoruro
de sodio miren más bien están
relacionados por unión de sodio
así que tampoco son un par conjugado ha
sido base entonces en este vídeo
aprendimos que para que algo sea un par
conjugado ha sido base debemos de tener
dos especies que tienen la misma fórmula
excepto que una de ellas tiene un protón
extra el ácido tiene un protón extra que
puede perder para formar la base